hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday July 13th 2020
hey how come how come that's not bad
luck how come just like the number 13
you know every month isn't bad if it's
Friday the 13th how the way the [ __ ] did
that come from
well those interesting questions and
those will be answered the next hour I
actually have a couple announcements to
make all right Nate bargatze one of the
funniest comedians and best joke writers
I know has a new podcast on the all
things comedy Network called Nate LAN
premiered last week subscribe on iTunes
Spotify and wherever else podcasts are
available and Paul dude I called it
virzi who's our next guest on the bill
Bert podcast has a new show and network
dude I called it what guests tell about
the time they called something and make
future predictions this week bill burr
that's me KFC from barstool sports and
Tom Green look at those big guests I'm
not saying I'm a big guest but there's a
lot of guys subscribe on YouTube all
right let's get down to [ __ ] why
Friday the 13 why is Friday the 13th you
guys know you want to know the [ __ ]
answer unlucky why is it unlucky oh is
that because Jesus got his [ __ ] get
nailed to the fence there or some [ __ ]
off by shuffling digits of the number
wait a second Friday the 13th all right
it's considered unlucky day in Western
superstition it occurs when the 13th day
of the month in the Gregorian calendar
falls on Friday which happens at least
once every year but can occur up to
three times in the same year for example
in 2015 Friday the 13th occurred yeah
but why
all right the irrational fear I like
that I like the way Wikipedia wrote this
the irrational fear of the number 13 has
been given a scientific name tricks God
they did it's a kind of phobia
and on analogy to this fear Friday 13th
is called who gives a [ __ ] according to
historian Donald dossie ah the great
double date he like the ladies with the
big tape you just scared the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of me
my eyes are going bad you just came
walking in heat and tell me coming out
here my wife just walked in oh you did
there's a mouse in the house ok ok so
it's in it all right
Oh for [ __ ] sakes no I'll get it I'll
kill the phone I'm not gonna kill her
I'm gonna let it out the [ __ ] side
though it's definitely in there what did
you make sure the things not gonna come
running back out underneath the door did
you put anything under the door no yeah
Jesus Christ so what am i doing now what
am i doing am I going over there get rid
of this [ __ ] thing or my or my
finishing the this is what you do walk
outside the house open the door to the
laundry room and just [ __ ] let the
thing then open the just let the thing
run out you think you're scared you
should try being the mouse thinks you're
gonna eat it you know what don't do
anything just don't do anything all
right you know what I'm gonna go now
because the [ __ ] thing cuz we got it
right now all right hang on a second
everybody all right I'm back I'm back
was it a mouse it was a [ __ ] rat
walking halfway back to the house you
guys they had a really long tail I'm
like how long does the tail when she can
he's like this big
how big was the body well yeah that's a
[ __ ] red it was long gone by the time
I got there so I grabbed my kid grabbed
my kids little [ __ ] aluminum baseball
bat I was walking in there going like
this is stupid
should have got like a [ __ ] mop
handle get a little distance between me
and that [ __ ] thing it's got the next
co vid so so there you go I'll tell you
people get yourself an old house you
know it's got character it's got [ __ ]
varmints I got a deal with that [ __ ]
yeah that's just part of living here you
know I remember when when my wife was
pregnant with my daughter you know we
rented this house because they were
redoing the kitchen one of the last
[ __ ] things we had to do on the house
so it'd be brand-new kitchen
everything's ready to go everything's up
to date for when the kiddo gets here and
of course we rent this [ __ ] house and
one night my wife was upstairs and had a
bunch of buddies of mine over smoking
cigars and [ __ ] there was a [ __ ]
mouse in the goddamn house and my guy
let's get this thing and you can't tell
my wife that it's in here
or else we're gonna have to rent a
different house I don't want to [ __ ]
deal with this [ __ ] I swear to god you
could end any woman rally all they need
to do is let a couple of mice go and
it's it's a [ __ ] wrap all that
warrior all of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that they're talking about I literally
was excited when she once I realized it
was her you know my [ __ ] eyes ago I
got to get some classes I thought she
want to come on the podcast you know no
I have another job just [ __ ] uh I
gotta be honest with you that's what's
killing me I love being a parent I love
being a husband but this [ __ ]
[ __ ] we're all they do all they do
is ask about your kids and your wife oh
she had another one oh god bless her oh
how is she doing oh that's great how are
they kid not a [ __ ] peep not a peep
about the [ __ ] guy I I have done more
[ __ ] jobs in the last 60 [ __ ]
minutes getting ready to go do this
thing you know I had to [ __ ] take a
stepladder put this goddamn [ __ ] up
on top of these shelves take the
stepladder down bring that thing down
there's too much you know she orders all
this [ __ ] food there's not enough
[ __ ] room in the fridge now I gotta
get the goddamn bread out
bring it out here to the garage sticking
this little ass [ __ ] fridge do that I
got to get the kid a [ __ ] bath and
the kids got into bubbles but all of
this [ __ ] non [ __ ] stop don't stop
and all I want to do is come out of here
find out why Friday the 13th is unlucky
and all of a sudden she goes bad job
here 9:20 at night by the way I'm
knocking this [ __ ] thing out Sunday
night cuz I got a bunch of [ __ ]
tomorrow everybody was standing around
bored out of their [ __ ] minds oh god
now I gotta have some other [ __ ]
another guy coming over here more
[ __ ] money more money more money no
gigs no gigs more money so we go out to
dinner tonight right we had a great time
by the way didn't go out today and went
out to go pick the [ __ ] [ __ ] up so I
go to this place the smokehouse in the
valley I love that place right so we
ordered a bunch of [ __ ] food and
we're standing in there waiting for a
[ __ ] order and this fat [ __ ] comes in
right he's got a [ __ ] mask on but you
know fatties you know they are they're
about immediate gratification because
he's so [ __ ] fat he can't deal with
his hot breath behind the mast of the
[ __ ] dope pulls his mast down it's
just standing there with it over his
mouth as he's breathing through his nose
I swear to God I swear to God
what do you need to know to get a
driver's license I can't believe that
people can be that [ __ ] stupid and
still have a [ __ ] license to drive
down the street into a [ __ ] crowd of
people cuz it's so [ __ ] stupid
how [ __ ] dumb are you jesus [ __ ]
christ i swear to god this whole [ __ ]
like just lowering the goddamn bar it's
just [ __ ] ridiculous
they just keep lowering the [ __ ] bar
and everybody's proud and everybody's a
[ __ ] hero and you know what no one's
getting the job done this was a [ __ ]
adult who you know has procreated and he
can't even [ __ ] put on a mask right
the co feeds over in my mouth would you
go down on a bat and [ __ ] Hong Kong
you [ __ ] more I I can't I can't deal
with that can't deal with all right
whatever plowing ahead plowing ahead all
right according to folklore historian
double-date Donald dicey the unlucky
nature of the number thirteen originated
with a Norse myth no it's Norse does
that mean Nordic I hate Wikipedia he
just it's just when you think you did
that this level dumb Norse mythology is
a body of myths of the North Germanic
peoples oh Jesus my people we had a
rough last century okay you know we got
a little beside ourselves all right
where is it the Norse something or other
what the [ __ ] is it I just had a double
D the trickster that I just blow past
all of this according to folklore the
unlucky number 13 walk it was a North
Smith about 12 God's having a dinner
party in Valhalla
the trickster god Loki who was not
invited yeah let me guess and 12 people
didn't want him to be there this is the
Isaiah Thomas of the [ __ ] you know of
the gods and he's still what blaming
everybody else you know I had I had
enough miracles to be there who was not
invited arrived as the 13th guest Anna
raged for hooah however you say that H
oor with some squiggles over the top who
to shoot Balder it must have been my
[ __ ] incest with a mistletoe tipped
arrow
dossie says Balder died in the whole
earth got dark oh so so this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
Loki told this [ __ ] to shoot Balder cuz
Balder probably didn't invite Loki you
know and [ __ ] had [ __ ] daddy issues
so she went ahead and did it is that
what happened
so the whole earth got dark in mourned
it was a bad unlucky day she's that
[ __ ] [ __ ] story is why people get
nervous this is why you have to look up
superstitions do you ever hear the one
that had on a hat on a bed his unlucky
and that was because I guess back in the
day when people would take that woolen
hats off you know they had a full head
of hair unlike me you know they get
static electricity and they'd see like
the [ __ ] the sparks in the hair so
people thought the devil was in your
hair so it was in your hair and you had
your hat on it was also in your hat put
the Hat on the bed then the devil was in
your bed and was gonna [ __ ] take your
spirit somehow the fact that it was
sitting on your [ __ ] head was not a
problem you know I'm surprised people
didn't shave their heads anyways let
Bill let's take the [ __ ] tension down
here shall we
ah god damn [ __ ] rat in my [ __ ]
house I got two [ __ ] kids in there
[ __ ] little bastards now what do I do
when I sleep in my daughter's room
tonight I think I got to do that little
[ __ ] anyway I'll figure it out so
anyways what the hell was I talking
about here just trying to have a good
time here on the podcast I've been
watching a bunch of drum videos and [ __ ]
you know but looking at different drum
heads and [ __ ] because I was sitting
behind my mic kit and I was just not
having fun lately and I was just like
I'm just stuck I'm working on the same
[ __ ] I'm not getting any better I'm just
spinning my wheels here I'm sick of
playing to the same [ __ ] songs and
all of this [ __ ] and you know what I did
I I guess you can't say you don't tune a
drum you tension it for all you drum
nerds out there I just I just detuned
attention to whatever and then just
retuned up my [ __ ] snare drum and
just that alone was a different sound
and it made it sound just a little fresh
or something different then I was like
you know what I'm gonna get some new
drum heads seized one seemed like
[ __ ] worn out I've had them since
I've owned the kit
which I got a couple years ago so I
usually just changed out the snare drum
head and I actually broke a bass drum
batter side head because I didn't have
those little sticky things on there so I
got that fixed up so I know how to do
that so now yeah I'll [ __ ] with the
Tom's do something but I've gone down
some Vinnie Paul of Pantera rabbit holes
but like lately I've just been really
just analyzing his drum parts and how
they fit in with what everybody's doing
including the singer and all that and
god dammit what a genius that guy was I
was lucky enough to meet him a number of
times and came out to shows and [ __ ] we
only hung out a couple of times we was
such a great great guy humble guy and
all of that but uh I always loved that
song [ __ ] hostel off of that album
I'm not the biggest I don't I always
[ __ ] these things up though uh has that
vulgar display for the kids getting
punched in the face in the mosh pit the
way he just puts that together the way
the whole thing as is essentially ednan
most of their [ __ ] isn't for then
they'll throw something weird in there I
haven't really broken it down yet but
just his his phrasing the balls and the
groove of everything that that guy
[ __ ] does I'm I am totally obsessed
with that band in his and Vinnie Paul's
playing right now so I've been having a
good time with that and my wife was
playing some music the other day some
band I forget the [ __ ] band
I'm the worst what the hell is it I'm
just trying to calm down cuz told my
wife they're trying to help me out here
with my [ __ ] anger issues all right
what the okay I'm gonna look up this the
band here it was this isn't it Oh Sol
coughing she started playing a bunch of
their stuff
you get the ankles I'll get the wrists
and all that and I was I [ __ ] love
this Bama this how did I miss this [ __ ]
when it first came out and she goes yeah
that was the band they took played that
let the man go through song on the the
Jordan documentary you were watching I
was like oh is that is that who said it
did that yeah so I've been trying to
listen to some new [ __ ] music or
whatever I dude I miss doing stand-up
like I I can't even tell you how bad I
miss just going out and making people
[ __ ] laugh it's my sole purpose on
the planet everything else in life I've
sucked at and I can't do that and it's
driving me up the [ __ ] wall I almost
wish I could go back in time in my life
when I had a day job that I hated but
then I wouldn't be broke and I'd be
wondering where the [ __ ] I was gonna be
I was gonna be able to pay my rent so I
don't know but you know what f1 is back
Formula One racing is back somehow I
missed the first race trying to avoid
CNN and Fox News which I swear to God I
really think at this point the
government needs to intervene and they
need to break up both of those channels
and they have to go back to regulating
media ownership of media because I've
really just come down to the fact that I
just think that this whole Kovan thing
is just showing the world how divided
Valle nerble in week this nation is
right now the fact that we all can't get
on the same [ __ ] page over over the
over a goddamn flu or whatever the [ __ ]
it is just blows my [ __ ] mind
it's so bad it is so [ __ ] bad and all
these [ __ ] lefties who think if
they've if they vote Donald Trump out
that it's gonna get better
like Fox News is then not just gonna
attack Joe Biden who whoever his entire
time in office yeah I just feel like
since Bill Clinton on all we do is just
attack our leader the entire [ __ ] how
can you get anything done
everyone half the country's flick in the
back of your [ __ ] ear for one to two
terms I don't know who knows but f1 is
f1 Racing is back I missed the first
race I
looked at I actually watched some
highlights I saw what happened I was
amazed that I saw that that Lewis
Hamilton didn't make it to the podium
and then I watched the highlights and
that's like oh yeah yeah yeah that [ __ ]
he moved that he does oh I thought I I
thought I gave him enough room I didn't
know what I was doing he is a master at
driving people off of the [ __ ] track
and somehow doing no damage to his car I
think that's one of one of another
amazing skill set that that guy has and
all he got was a five-second [ __ ]
penalty but I still love the guy and
everything but he's definitely I don't
know
he definitely has like that [ __ ] diva
thing where it's just like he there's a
set of rules for him and then everybody
else you know he reminds me a couple of
comics I knew coming up just complete
[ __ ] narcissists you know as far as
like how he treats his teammate like he
expects his teammate to do [ __ ] for him
when he needs it [ __ ] that he would
never do for valtteri botas ever ever I
don't like that [ __ ] that's that's
that's my only knock against that guy
other than he's other than that he's
[ __ ] amazing and I feel fortunate
that I did get to see him drive live a
couple of times because I know someday
I'll tell my kids that that guy was the
greatest driver of all time as far as my
you know at least the era now before I
get everybody [ __ ] yelling at me
about past drivers that I don't know
about admitting Lee here but alright
let's talk about the race from today or
actually you'll be yesterday by the time
you hear this is first of all how great
to the new mercedes-benz cars looked
race car whatever the [ __ ] you call it I
mean even if you didn't know [ __ ] about
f1 like I don't if you just looked at
the cars you like okay that car is
[ __ ] winning that's it right there
alright everybody else looks like
they're in the matrix and that thing
looks like it's the [ __ ] Illuminati
controlling the matrix and this is all I
need to enjoy this shortened season
which i think is an advantage to every
other racing team because in a full
season they haven't been able to touch
Mercedes is all I need is for for up for
Ferrari
- I don't be Ferrari like I don't know
what the [ __ ] problem is and I I've
lost track how many times the two team
the teammates on Ferrari have taken each
other out of the [ __ ] race I just
need them to stop doing that
and to be competitive with Mercedes and
all I need is redbull to give max
Verstappen a competitive car if I can
just see that then maybe I can see some
sort of excitement because I'll tell you
as far as watching the race today other
than the shock of seeing Ferrari
slamming to each other once again and
take each other out of the race
the best part of the race was max
Verstappen trying to hold up fell
Thierry botas I was off my seat I was
screaming and yelling at the TV hope and
Max for stopping could hold them off
even though I love both those drivers
you know it's like that's what what
makes racing exciting is competition in
passing and that type of thing and I
don't know what the cars are so [ __ ]
big now I don't know they either need to
make the tracks wider
I don't know what they need to do but
there it's just like once Lewis Hamilton
is out front I've been saying this for
five years they don't even show the guy
he's so far out in front that the race
is just over like the best race I wish I
watched a few weeks ago the first one
when you come out of the first turn in
Lewis isn't in first place so at least
you're gonna see some sort of racing
where he tries to work his way back up
to the front it's still a great sport
and that type of thing but I just don't
understand why Ferrari with all of their
money just can't seem to keep up with
Mercedes I don't know what the hell
they're doing but I know I was probably
too hard on Lewis Hamilton early on I
just get frustrated that I just know
he's going to win ever
and it just gets boring and you just
want like somebody to challenge him it's
like [ __ ] watching the Golden State
Warriors when they had a Kevin Durant
that once then that season he first came
there and every was just like well
they're gonna win it all and then they
did it was just that's just [ __ ]
boring as hell
anyways but I am psyched that it's back
and I was actually joking on Bill Burt
that I was thinking that maybe it's
actually it's better for the environment
that a couple hundred thousand people
don't show up you know by all these
t-shirts and take shits and
porta-potties if they just [ __ ] stay
home you know I don't know I don't miss
it I also watch the UFC and I really
enjoyed that fight card and I liked the
last fight a lot of I know a lot of
people didn't I was just fascinated that
was like watching Belichick taking away
you know well back in the day when we
play Peyton Manning and he was part of a
three-headed monster and you would just
watch Belichick just take it all away
and they would go from this [ __ ] just
electrifying team to a team that was
just shaking their head and not knowing
what the [ __ ] was going on I mean I know
the other dude I might go with the names
I know that that guy's a beast he's one
of the greatest ever did it and he
didn't really have a long training camp
or whatever so I hope that that's going
to be a rematch but like I had no
problem with the foot stompin that was
impressed with that tactic and I was
even more impressed that the other dude
could sit there and have a champions
stomping his heel down on his big toe
and not even [ __ ] register any sort
of pain he would have stomped on my toe
one [ __ ] time that would have been
the end of the fight that would have
been the end of my month would have been
it over [ __ ] rap but uh I like I said
I don't know any the [ __ ] names I
like watching that rematch of rose first
that little fire hydrant chick man she
was amazing she just does not get marked
up unbelievable chin
that was one of those ones why I thought
that was the right decision was made but
I thought if they fought five rounds I
think the the the little fire hydrant
chick would have won sorry I'm not gonna
go back and try to remember the [ __ ]
names all right I'm sorry and then the
other guy that other fight with the tall
lanky guy he built like Tommy hit man
her and somehow 5 foot 11 but making 145
pound way to some [ __ ] whatever he
was doing that dude got [ __ ] robbed
he got [ __ ] robbed I don't know what
the hell that was about but every every
all the other ones I saw I thought were
I thought they were good so thank God
for the UFC thank God for f1 racing
thank God baseball is coming back MotoGP
the best racing that there is starts
next week I believe right I'm so [ __ ]
excited for this I need something MotoGP
2020 here we go yeah for the first time
in my life and a long time in like 20
years I've been in a consistently like
negative mood and I am I don't know how
to get out of his [ __ ] I'm just you know
what I did was I went on and I actually
watched a little bit of the news and
then I just read some [ __ ] that was
trending and that that's not ain't good
for me all right so what the [ __ ] this
this is the 20/20 calendar for MotoGP
and they go on all the way back to March
8th
oh wait did they do one race they
actually did a race and I missed it
March 8th that's right I missed it and
then March 10th I did Dean Del Rey's
ACDC show then the next day they just
shut everything down I have a [ __ ]
MotoGP race to watch where do I watch it
MotoGP calm all right July 19th next
week on Sunday they have the one in
Spain it's gonna be great oh my god I
can't believe it
now they're not gonna take a break in
August are they
like they usually do well look at this
we'll look at this we're gonna get we
got the March 8th race then they got one
two this three six no three five eight
eleven
what's eleven and three 14 17 races left
that's [ __ ] amazing
alright so there's that to look forward
to anyway I don't even know what the
[ __ ] to talked about anymore I got a
goddamn rat problem you know like
there's only one oh my god ladies and
gentlemen we got a rat in the house
where the [ __ ] could it be coming from
probably underneath the house under the
house and then somehow you know because
whoever some somebody's [ __ ] uncle
didn't do something right in the
nineteen [ __ ] 40s or some [ __ ] I have
no idea I gotta figure out where that
[ __ ] is coming from I have a
nice clean house what the [ __ ] it was
smelling was it getting chased by a
snake and just kind of accidentally
ended up do I have a family of them
living under my house I'm [ __ ]
believable you know if this this a few
animals I have no problem killing and
rats are one of them I don't rats are
basically just furry mosquitoes I mean
there's a zillion [ __ ] mosquitoes I
have no problem killing a [ __ ]
mosquito I would kill a [ __ ] right I
want to make a mess no Jesus Christ you
know my wife won't let me have a gun
won't let me get a gun you know I could
have taken out a nice [ __ ] 38 [ __ ]
special
I know what wallets in I know where I
just felt like there was no way I don't
know I don't know if it you know those
[ __ ] things could squeeze underneath
[ __ ] I think it we had certain our
laundry room and the [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
right the [ __ ] [ __ ] who put
the goddamn thing in you know where the
the plumbing goes in the this space
they're supposed to fill that [ __ ]
space in you know I mean other than the
fact that house hasn't fault that just
fell down I've had I've didn't do
everything else to this [ __ ] thing oh
my god here we go again here we go again
anyway I thought that the hold all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] with Will Smith and
what's-her-face there it's just just
[ __ ] amazing just watching women
making excuses for the chick you don't I
mean and then everybody making fun of
the guy you know in that situation it's
just so [ __ ] funny to me it's like
can you imagine that [ __ ] if a guy did
that and then you're making excuses for
the guy and then you're making [ __ ]
memes and humiliating [ __ ] memes of
the woman there whatever them whatever
her name is you know Will Smith's wife
unbelievable people are so [ __ ] me
they're going through a horrible time
right now can you [ __ ] leave them
alone I was gonna say what's going on in
your life that you give a [ __ ] it's like
nothing nothing's going on in my life so
I have time to pay attention to that
[ __ ] well I hope they get through it
because they've been together forever
and they got a bunch of kids and yeah
it's none of your [ __ ] business kind
of a [ __ ] [ __ ] I should wash I
should talk I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] but
I'm just saying sees two people going
through that level of pain like they're
not going through enough level pain now
you got to make a little [ __ ] meme to
make fun of them you know and be like
I'm the guy who created the Will Smith
cry and me but just like what the [ __ ]
you know does that person gets canceled
[ __ ] no all right butcher box everybody
all my favorite butcher box you know
when it comes to meat all I'm thinking
right now is that [ __ ] rat when it
comes to meat quality matters there's
more to it than texture and taste
butcher box is better for you better for
animals and better for the environment
what's your favorite cut of meat how do
you like to prepare it what do I like I
like a [ __ ] ribeye favorite cut of
meat I mean that's like that's like
saying what's your favorite uh your
favorite Super Bowl I mean all of them
even the ones my team lost because it
made the ones when they won was even
better I like every kind of meat from
[ __ ] cube steaks right up to a
[ __ ] what they call a Steamship round
what do they call that when you eat like
the whole [ __ ] ass of the cow what
does that thing
it's a giant cutting weight still enough
[ __ ] ain't the wrong things yeah
sorry people this podcast is gonna suck
because there's a [ __ ] rat in my
house Steamship round yeah that's it
that's it that's the Fred Flintstone cut
what is a Steamship round cut no no I
want images images here there it is yo
kills me and get one for 130 bucks slow
cooked that [ __ ] that thing is gigantic
that could feed you for [ __ ] three
months if you knew how to keep it going
thought it goin bad anyway where am i
where am I at what's my favorite cut of
meat all of them I love it
I'm a carnivore it can be hard to find a
hundred percent grass-fed slash finished
beef free-range organic chicken heritage
breed pork oh my favorite
or wild-caught salmon at the grocery
store and it can be expensive if you do
find it luckily there's butcher bucks
though out of all the products this is
the one I've really used and I stand by
these guys they're cut Samhita great
butcher bucks believes everyone deserves
high-quality humanely
sourced meat never be without someone to
cook for dinner because there's always
meet in the never be without something
to cook for dinner because there's
always meat in the freezer
one less trip to the grocery store and a
better more affordable selection to Yen
you don't have to put on a mask either
all meat is free of antibiotics and
added hormones each box has nine to
eleven pounds of meat enough for 24
individual meals unless you like that
fat bastard then does not aware a
[ __ ] mask probably ate it in two
sittings packed fresh and shipped frozen
and vacuum sealed so it stays that way
you can customize your box or go with
one of theirs either way you get exactly
what you want butcher bucks is the most
affordable and convenient way to get
healthy humanely raised meet with
butcher bucks you get the highest
quality meat for around just six bucks a
meal and they even have free shipping
nationwide except for Alaska and Hawaii
so mark a visit to the meat counter off
your list and receive quality meats
delivered to your door now just go to
butcher box com / / that's butcher bucks
com / / John that's making me wonder how
the [ __ ] we got Alaska stamps.com
everybody for all our sakes we need to
do our best to avoid crowds anywhere we
can right now but what if you need to go
to the post office yeah I need to go to
the post office and find one of those
[ __ ] lunatics that works down here to
come down and shoot one of these [ __ ]
rats what if you need postage to send
out letters and packages
that's why you need stamps com anything
you can do with the post office you can
do it stamps calm yeah can I drop the
[ __ ] scale on that rats head print
postage on demand and skip those lines
and crowds at the post office as if that
wasn't enough stamps combo so offers UPS
services with discounts up to 62% and no
UPS residential surcharges you've heard
me talk about stamps con they've been
sponsoring this show for over seven
years now and even if you haven't tried
it what are you waiting for whether
you're a small business sending invoices
and online sellers shipping out products
to some [ __ ] bald redheaded come with
a radness house you can handle it all
with these simply use your computer to
print out official US postage
24/7 for any letter any package any
class of mail any way you want to send
it once your mail is ready just leave
your mail carrier just leave it for your
mail carrier schedule is free package
pick up or drop it in a mailbox no human
contact required it's that simple and
like I said with stamps calm you get
great discounts to five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 62 percent
off USPS the United States Postal
Service shipping rates stamp calm is a
no-brainer especially now saving you
time and money and keeping you safe in
these crazy times all I'm thinking about
is where this [ __ ] rat could have
gotten into my house right now my
listeners get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus a free
free postage and a digital scale that I
might drop of that thing's head without
any long-term commitment just go to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in bar
that's stamps comm enter ber stay safe
my friends I'm already thinking about
going to the pet store and buying a boa
constrictor and leaving it in my [ __ ]
oh you can just call an exterminator
bill yeah okay that's what I'll do all
right that's what the [ __ ] I'm gonna do
I've been watching all these goddamn
animal videos you know I'm literally
down to leopard verse sita i watched a
fox kill a cat
i'll tell you somethin bout cats man
those things don't give a [ __ ] they got
balls like most of the fox fox has
realized it wasn't worth it you know and
everybody's saying a fox is it's like it
looks like a dog but it has cat
quickness and those things just like
that's not a good death gettin eaten by
a fox man those [ __ ] things yeah they
just you know that little [ __ ] needle
nose and those goddamn teeth i've been
watching all of that [ __ ] I've been
watching ly so I watched a [ __ ] tiger
up in a tree trying to figure out how to
kill this monkey the monkeys all the way
on the the the lights the all the way on
the the furthest part of the branches
where the tiger knows the [ __ ] trees
gonna collapse and it's just sitting
there
and I swear to God it can smell the
Tigers breath and the breath that the
tiger knows if it moves any further the
things gonna it's gonna snap you know
think but it's like 600 pounds and this
[ __ ] thing kept inching its way out
and finally the I don't know it just
fell out of the tree and the monkey ran
back up the tree and then the tiger just
sat down there with like this look on
its face like a [ __ ] what are you gonna
do the [ __ ] are you gonna do I didn't
know that many things [ __ ] with
monkeys leopards kill monkeys Lions kill
monkeys these are all the things I've
seen kill monkeys leopards lions people
I saw a tiger try to do it so if he
tried that means they do it not that
there was any evidence of it you know
other than it tried what else have I
seen alligators crocodiles when they you
know during the dry season I always root
against him - I [ __ ] hate him not
hate him enough to ever do any less I
like a rang in tanzanite I don't like
monkeys I don't like those [ __ ]
bastards and I don't like chimpanzees I
just don't like them you know I do
I just don't they I don't like any
animal that [ __ ] eats another animal
alive if it's a reptile I get it you're
a [ __ ] dope but if you're a mint if
you're a mammal you should have the
[ __ ] decency to just kill the thing
first you know I don't like those little
wild dogs they do the same thing you
know this is you know some I really this
it it [ __ ] with your head to watch
those videos I gotta stop watching them
it's [ __ ] hilarious I quit watching
porn and now I'm watching animals kill
each other I mean what is wrong with me
you know I'll tell you right now I would
love to have a pack of wild dogs right
now [ __ ] under my house ripping that
rat apart as long as they agreed to
leave afterwards you know I think we can
work it out get a document together
everybody could be happy what
all right new segment recommendation
from somebody hey Billy Bojangles I'd
like to recommend a new write-in segment
after every Thursday afternoon podcast
familis plays a podcast from the same
day back in 2012 during those podcasts
we hear from people who ask for your
advice with their relationship or
confrontations with neighbors now that
it's 2020 I would expect that those
issues to be fully resolved and I would
love to hear from those same people
again regarding how everything turned
out that's a good idea but it's also
they got to be listening granted that's
putting a lot of faith and hope that
they're still listening to your podcast
he just said I'm still I'm saying this
because I'm going through a difficult
breakup right now and would love to get
some perspective from people who are
eight years out from theirs and hear how
their issues ended up working out might
make for some good stories yeah you hang
in there man you're gonna be fine
you're gonna be fine and you're gonna
find the right person and then one day
you know you're gonna when you find the
right person you just look back at the
other person you like how the [ __ ] did I
ever you know you don't even think about
him in when you know you truly passed
him when you wish him no ill will you
know one of my first girlfriends I mean
she [ __ ] cheated on me and all of
this [ __ ] [ __ ] just really just
ruined my whole [ __ ] perspective on
the whole romance thing I was just like
this is what this is [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and you know good 15 years of stand-up
comedy I was able to work my way out of
it now did you'll be fine you're not a
psycho like me I imagine you'll be fine
you just gotta understand that going
through a breakup is painful and you got
to go through it there's no shortcuts
that's it but I do know women get
through them quicker because they emot--
and they cry so I don't know who you can
talk to to do that but maybe you know
what for guys cuz we're not allowed to
cry maybe you could take like an old
volleyball like Tom Hanks in that
[ __ ] Island movie
you know have you and just cry to Wilson
well shut banks and Islam oh this is
interesting I have no idea how the banks
work oh ok hi hi bill I've been
listening to the mmm podcast for a long
time and always enjoy your rants on the
banking system since I totally agree
with you I always thought that Islamic
banking was a more fair system but I am
certainly bias since I am Muslim well
tell me how it works he goes however I
will try to explain it to you in my
limited English so you can make your own
opinion
oh right do you crush in your English
you know I don't know if you used an app
and it just translated it but if this is
your English it's pretty amazing in
Islam it's is basically forbidden to
generate wealth by accumulating wealth
ok you already lost me what is it you
can't generate wealth by accumulating
wealth I don't even know meaning ok ok
just read a bill he'll explain meaning
that interests on money or anything are
illegal so you have no interest so for
people to borrow money and have a reward
for the bank who lends money they have
to share the risks and the profits for
example if you want to open a business
and need 1,200 bucks the bank will lend
you the money but they will have a share
in your business like 5050 it sounds
like you went to the mob 5050 and
profits what but when you make your
monthly payments to pay your debt to the
bank is that just through the life of
the loan or for the rest of your
business but when you make your monthly
payments to pay your debt to the bank
you pay $100 a month and no interest the
bank gets 50 percent of your profits on
that month but only if you made some
money the downside is that the bank owns
half of your bank half your business but
you can buy those 50 percent back
little by little though come on man this
is six of one half dozen of the other
they're still bleeding you dry they're
not in that example if your business is
valued at 2,000 you can pay $110 a month
to the bank and those ten dollars will
be will by one percent of the bank's
share plus next month you can only give
them 49 percent of the profits dude
they're still [ __ ] you they're still
[ __ ] you over in the case of the
business failing unless I'm too stupid
understanding which is always on the
table here if in the case of the
business failing after let's say six
month the bank loses $600 and you lose
six months of time and effort I hope it
makes some sense to you love your comedy
and podcasts and yacht - fare uncool I
think that's French for go [ __ ] yourself
I'm probably valve vato fare uncool PS
if you want to read more about this
there is a great example on the Islamic
on the the exalt Islamic banking and
finance Wikipedia page yeah do it cuz
that's just sounded like yeah we won't
charge you interest but we own half your
business forever even after I pay the
[ __ ] thing back it's kind of isn't
that it's just you're just not calling
an interest alright and aren't they
accumulating wealth by taking half of my
[ __ ] profits and then also making me
oh them that money twice as long
Oh bill you could look it all up alright
Islamic banking and financing Wikipedia
all right here we go Islamic Islamic
banking and finance I can tell you it
can't be any worse than the [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're doing over here wiki pedia all
right here we go what do we got here
Islamic banking and financing Wikipedia
oh my God look how far
get along this is not reading all of
this alright dude I'm gonna take your
word for it
sorry it's late at night I'll read up on
it I I do I do find it fascinating like
a different way of doing it but I and
generally speaking I wherever you are
and if there's a bank am i I wouldn't
trust them
I wouldn't think no pun intended they
have your best interests
interest chicken intelligent continued
intelligence continued this this is so
fascinating to me chickens can count up
to 10 which is what I said that's why
you should have at least eleven chicken
so if you want to kill one of he it they
won't [ __ ] notice one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten I mean do
we yeah we we had at least ten anyway at
least ten all right hey Bill I listened
to your podcast at the troubadour and I
gladly gave them a donation thank you so
much for doing that and yes the sound
could have been better but you know but
you know that alright you read my email
about chickens coincidentally you read
it on my birthday well there you go and
you complain that I left out all the
gory Ed Gein details of chicken
cannibalism usually people don't like
hearing that stuff but I forgot that you
were enjoying watching videos of animals
killing each other I found it more
fascinating so this sort of thing but I
can watch him kill it I can't watch him
hold it down and start eating I can't do
that alright so this sort of thing is
right up your alley here we go when
chickens see a wounded chicken their
instinct is to peck the chicken to death
and eat it maybe that instinct helped
them against predators long ago somehow
but it is a nuisance now chickens are
often injured by being pecked at by
other chickens that are stressed an
amazing list of things can stress them
and trigger an orgy of cannibalism too
lean of a diet too rich of a diet not
enough fiber in the diet changing the
model of their feeder moving them to
another pen too much sunlight Jesus
Christ these things are temperamental
putting different colored chickens in
the same pen
and their racist they get curious and
start pecking at each other adding new
chickens in an occupied pen which
confuses the pecking order boredom
accidentally leaving any cannibalized
chicken remains in a pen they are
especially set off by any sight of blood
with laying hens sometimes there's a
trace of blood when they lay eggs and
there is a chance that other hens will
Peck the new mother to death and eat her
instead of giving her a proper baby
shower
what the [ __ ] one way to stop the blood
fury is in chickens is to use a special
red light bulb in the pen which makes
them unable to see the color of blood
does that work with serial killers like
if they work in one of those little
photo mats developing photos do they
stop having the urge to kill people my
grandfather would often put a red tinted
cellophane cover on the main window that
had the same effect and that would calm
them down also if a chicken is wounded
there are wound paints that can be used
to hide the blood and they are also and
they are they also are designed to taste
terrible to help stop the pecking
another option that my grandfather used
was to try and spot the most aggressive
chickens and make a chicken dinner out
of them there is also a problem with
laying hens when they start somehow
discovering that eggs are delicious and
start eating them when the ruined eggs
are discovered the offending chicken has
to be quickly caught and killed another
chicken dinner before the other hens
become curious and start copying her
behavior again no one should feel any
guilt about eating chickens since they
they too enjoy eating chickens still in
the sticks go [ __ ] yourself hey they
never tell you this [ __ ] all these
people who want to have [ __ ] you know
chickens and [ __ ] in their backyard so
they can get them organic eggs they
don't realize that they're going to have
alright
chicken
and cannibalism cannibalism videos do I
do it
cannibal chickens how to stop
cannibalism and chickens cannibalism or
aggressive pecking oh my god here's a
minute forty video this is not the right
music our chickens cannibal alright
Marjorie Wildcat if you don't show me a
pen a [ __ ] chicken pecking another
one a shut up just shut up Marjorie
you're talking too much here we go oh my
god
fifty-five seconds in oh my god what the
[ __ ] dude - god bless farmers I swear to
god this [ __ ] that they see so we don't
have to [ __ ] see it now with YouTube
I just saw it you know they bring food -
you [ __ ] table and all of that [ __ ]
hey god bless him
god bless him what nah [ __ ] that I just
watch they just did wow it looked like
pulled pork they Peck this thing so bad
alright can't keep up with husbands
libido hi Bill I hope you're doing well
I love the podcasts you work on your
commitment to calling out today's
[ __ ] I can't get enough well thank
you anyway or at least calling out what
I consider to be [ __ ] not saying
it's actually [ __ ] anyway I'm
recently married I'm a recently married
late
oh by the way that was some [ __ ]
that I wanted to talk about fellow
comics when a comedian is involved in a
controversy that could possibly end
their career unless you have any
information to add to it you should
probably stay out of it like too
literally
recently I saw this like all of a sudden
other comedians feelings about the
person's act or whatever which has
nothing to do with what they're debating
it's just just you know speaking of
chicken cannibalism comedians shouldn't
like there's enough people trashing
comedians right now you don't need to
pile on I was really surprised with that
these past couple of weeks seeing the
amount of [ __ ] comedians that were
just [ __ ] ah this dude's a hack
anyway and blah blah blah it's like what
the [ __ ] does that have to do so what
it's not what we're talking about here
this is serious [ __ ] accusations and
somebody's career is in the balance who
gives a [ __ ] what you think about their
act Jesus Christ people let's can we
come together somewhere anywhere on any
level in any point in this country
anyways alright can't keep up with
husbands libido
anyway I'm recently married I'm a
recently married lady in a peculiar
situation I would really love your
advice to preface let me say that my
husband is the love of my life I adore
him and would never consider being with
anyone else as I grow old and see now
that being said he's insatiable when it
comes to sex I like intimacy just as the
next gal but I simply can't keep up I'm
more of a three times a week kind of
girl - that's plenty but he needs it
every [ __ ] day now I wouldn't be
asking for your help if the answer was
as simple as rubbing one out the problem
is that the relief is entirely different
between himself and the real deal I know
he isn't just making stuff up to get
some so please bear with me when he gets
horny I'm like this is just so out of my
wheelhouse here when he gets horny which
is every morning if I'm not in the mood
he'll take care of himself to start the
that being said he'll remain in a
bizarre state of numbness just being
morose in general Oh get the [ __ ] out of
here he's pouting he's giving you the
old [ __ ] pop no [ __ ] pout I don't buy
it he'll try to hide his darker
dispositions but I just sensed that he
isn't himself out of guilt I'll offer to
blow him but it gets very
psychologically draining when you aren't
in the right mental space for it yeah
absolutely
oh afterwards at least I feel like I get
my husband back mood wise the libido
mismatch doesn't only stop at his relief
it also affects the general dynamic in
the house I can't wear skimpy clothes a
god forbid I wanted to walk around naked
as I'll be relentlessly groped caressed
kissed and so on Jesus Christ it's like
you're married a [ __ ] Saint Bernard
in the spring there I love the attention
of course but it can interfere with the
course of what the attention I don't
know what to do here but it can
interfere with the course of the day
quite a bit I don't really know what to
think of it since I'm quite average
looking so I think it's just his natural
disposition all right that's called low
self-esteem sweetheart
we started weight training too and now
that he is fit
I just can't tire him out when we do
have sex well you need to start wearing
a ski Parker and start making them some
pies other than that I don't know what
the [ __ ] that's I don't this is Adam is
above my pay grade ultimately I just
feel inadequate as a wife I wish it was
just as simple as having sex with them
every day twice if I could do it I would
I just can't get myself to have sex that
often without causing mental strain for
myself I know it may sound weird to a
guy no it doesn't it's just how I and
many other female frame friends seem to
be wired so here goes what should I do
is there anything that can be done to
better the situation
I want I don't want to lose him nor do I
want to trap him in an unfulfilled
marriage please help can I ask you a
question
is he even as remotely concerned about
your needs as you are about his [ __ ]
this pouting [ __ ] [ __ ] how many
[ __ ] times you got to bang the guy I
think what you have to do is he's just
gonna have to realize that that you you
know just say listen here's the deal
I'll bang you three times a week
okay which is about two and a half more
times than most the broads out there
okay that's it that's my final offer
final answer I'm not phoning a friend
that's it I'm banging you three times a
[ __ ] week that's what I can handle I
love you you're the love of my life but
I can only [ __ ] three times a week okay
so you're gonna have to figure out you
know how to take that sourpuss lack of
[ __ ] look off your [ __ ] face cuz
I've had it all right in more ways than
one sweetheart you are bending over
backwards for this guy this guy can go
[ __ ] himself
all right I don't know what to tell you
I don't know if he needs to go get some
professional help you know did you marry
a [ __ ] 16 year old the [ __ ] is with
this guy I don't know tell him to go
[ __ ] jerk off I have no idea that was
just my gut that's what my gut says I
have no idea I would I would go seek
professional help on that one but have
you can well I mean I'm being a little
hard on him
no pun intended now Jesus all kinds of
innuendo here have you told him how this
makes you feel you know is there
anything worse than seeing a grown man
pouting Jesus Christ grow some [ __ ]
balls you [ __ ] girlfriend's mother is
also our landlord all right well this
relationships over hey Billy real estate
I'm with my girl now for about a year
and a half and we moved in together
about six months ago
okay before
any further did you already know that
your landlord was gonna be her mother
when searching for rental properties her
mother mentioned she planned to move out
of this out of the city but didn't want
to sell her home for whatever reason she
offered up the idea that we rented from
her move no lease pet-friendly etc I
thought sweet yeah you know they say
when something seems too good to be true
it usually is anyway we decided to move
in I thought having her mother as a
landlord would prove to be beneficial in
Cheaper all capital letters wrong the
estimated rent on the house is lower
than what we actually pay by a couple
hundred dollars her reasoning for that
is unexpected maintenance wait the unate
the estimated rent on the house is lower
than what we would actually pay so she
is giving you a break did you write that
correctly am i reading this wrong her
reasoning is that a reasoning for that
is unexpected maintenance I learned soon
after that the rent she is charging us
is actually the amount of her mortgage
her mortgages every month can't even cut
your own daughter a break well she is
she [ __ ] let you guys go in there
without first and last is she supposed
to take a loss on it why she rented it
to someone else she probably would have
rented a little more than the mortgage
she's just breaking even although she is
you know building equity in the house
she is also completely scatterbrain and
is no way to fit no is in no way fit to
be a landlord her mom agreed to pay the
water / trash for us since it's next to
nothing one day my girl calls me and
says the water may be getting shut off
because there was a mistake at the water
department [ __ ] I thought the water
company has been doing this [ __ ] forever
there's no billing error without either
these dumb broads knowledge I called the
water - you're already out of this
relationship you're calling the mother
your girlfriend a dumb broad in your
girlfriend a dumb broad
so I'm just gonna enjoy the rest of this
story I know this relationships over
without either of these dumb broads
knowledge I called the water department
myself and learned that she hadn't
played the bill in over five months then
proceeded to lie about it great
I have also become the handyman around
the house which is fine but half the
time the expenses are expected to come
out of my pocket and I'm always made out
to be the dick for speaking up since
this is my girls mom dude you should
take all of this as a learning
experience I've started to refuse to fix
anything which has resulted in windows
that don't lock doors that don't knobs
that don't turn and a deck that is one
soft blow away from toppling over she's
known about these problems for months
now I love my girl and we have a good
time together but I am starting to think
I need to remove myself from this
situation what do you think I thought
that from the second I [ __ ] read the
first sentence and then it was
solidified when you called your
girlfriend and your girlfriend's mom
dumb brats this has passed the point of
being able to be fixed her mom is a real
estate agent and I would I wouldn't even
consider buying a dollhouse from her
yeah dude you're out you don't want it
you don't want to breed with this family
you're not gonna marry this woman you're
done you're out the decisions already
been made maybe you just needed to hear
it from a complete stranger
congratulations sir you know what you
want to do now here's what you have to
do okay you don't want to break up and
then go look for a place okay what you
want to do is find a place get your
first and last in there okay you want to
do that you take a day off from [ __ ]
work when your girlfriend's at work all
right and you pack like a [ __ ]
lunatic that realizes the feds are gonna
be there in 20 minutes and you're
looking at life in prison you pack all
your [ __ ] up maybe with the buddy of
yours I guess you don't have to call in
sick cause you're [ __ ] I don't know
pandemic some people are working you get
all your [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of there you
put it in your new place then you sit it
down you say listen we need to talk she
says where's all your stuff you say
that's what
we need to talk about I don't want to go
out with you anymore yeah it's not me
it's you
it's not me it's not you it's your
mother and it is you get both a couple
of dumb brats don't say that just say
yeah that's what I want to talk about I
don't want to do this anymore
I'm not in love with you anymore I hate
my life here I don't like this you're a
sweetheart
you deserve to find love okay and then
that's it so you're leaving yes I am
leaving and then you [ __ ] leave and
then that's it and then it's over then
it's over you get the [ __ ] out of there
okay when breaking up with a woman you
need to get the [ __ ] out of there you
need to get the [ __ ] away from them okay
because they're gonna make you break up
with them fifty-eight [ __ ] times
they're gonna go through all the [ __ ]
emotion and then rabies you're starting
to get your [ __ ] together they're gonna
call you up and mind [ __ ] you and send
you back to square one again and they're
not gonna leave you alone until they
feel like they've inflicted enough pain
on you for you breaking up with them
that they not only they did they get
even they got a little better on you
that's what the [ __ ] gonna happen so
get the [ __ ] out of that situation
that's it okay that is it and that is
the podcast I have a rat I have to go
[ __ ] kill at least I'm gonna put a
contract out on its head go [ __ ]
yourselves
don't go [ __ ] yourself so you know what
that's divisive divisive divisive
divisive I think what's people let's try
to all get the same page comedians
please don't attack each other on
[ __ ] the internet when you're
commenting on a situation where you
weren't even there and you don't know
anybody involved please don't do that
people please stop watching Fox News
please stop watching me CNN please stop
attacking fellow Americans okay
just wear a [ __ ] mask it seems to be
working for every other [ __ ] country
out there I think they're all human
beings too I think they have the same
respiratory situation you know systems
we could do that or we could just scream
and yell at each other
and attack Donald Trump and if he gets
reattempt literally like to keep
attacking him
oh yeah you give Joe Biden and then just
[ __ ] attack him for four [ __ ]
years and see what that does for us
right that's it I want to read about
Islamic banking that's what I'm gonna do
all right god bless you all of you and
the United States of America and
wherever the [ __ ] you live okay bye